vegans aren't just coming after your
burgers they're coming after your words
phrases like killing two birds with one
stone now considered offensive to some
not to worry PETA has some animal
friendly alternatives here now is the
host of the Michael Noel's show Michael
Knowles joining us from LA Michael good
morning to you good to see you all right
we were just talking about some of the
PC police's latest things that they are
going after how about this one there's
apparently an academic at Swansea
University who says that idioms
involving animal products could be
rendered obsolete because they're out of
touch with today's society do you think
that's right well PETA is already
suggesting this they want to replace
beating a dead horse with feeding a fed
horse and it seems to me that the vegans
suggesting these things are a few fries
away from a happy meal is that one vegan
friendly the veganism is on the rise in
the last few years is up 360 percent in
the UK it's up 500 percent in the u.s.
that is not the problem a more veganism
means more veal for me and the problem
is the spread of this ideology and the
ideology is spreading and it's morally
incoherent we're told that we can't eat
eggs or milk or shellfish why stop there
an oyster is no more conscious than a
carrot and there's this irony too
PETA is telling people to use these new
bizarre expressions but every vegan that
I know is in favor of abortion
how many vegans are pro-life why do we
have to care about the delta smelt but
we can't care about unborn human babies
what it is is an inversion of the
natural order animals exist for our
enjoyment the environmentalists left
wants us to believe that we exist for
animals to serve animals which is not
true we we like animals we want to
conserve animals and ultimately we want
to serve animals to each other on a
dinner plate as you just said them I'm
gonna go more veal for you here is one
of the other expressions kill two birds
with one stone that's what is commonly
said now instead according to PETA you
should instead say feed two birds with
one scone which is great for the scone
the street it's really big Scone is
probably behind this one you know what
it would throw the trouble with these
expressions is that they don't make the
point that the expressions are trying to
make it's very easy to feed two birds
with one scone you could feed a hundred
birds with one scone birds don't eat
very much the expression is kill two
birds with one stone which means that
you are being very efficient in your
tactics the same thing how do you feed a
fed horse you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make him drink they're
really very confused about their idioms
well you know I get there saying look we
don't eat meat I get that and I respect
that but at the same time I think these
are just suggestions going forward but I
really don't see people stopping saying
I'm gonna bring home the bacon instead
saying I'm gonna bring home the bagels
in fact Orrin Hatch the US senator from
Utah after he heard they want you to say
bring home the bacon and instead used
bagel he just posted this video of him
eating just a lot of bacon which is just
kind of crazy got a love Orrin Hatch
this is the definition of political
correctness this is a small fanatical
cultish minority trying to foist their
ideological fantasies on the rest of us
and I think you're exactly right the way
that the culture is going to react to
this is by sitting right there and
eating a bunch of bacon every new
expression less I think I'll have
another piece please just fry some up
right now it looked delicious
Michel Noel's journey from La the City
of Angels thank you sir
good to see you Steve